Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody, hope everybody
celebrating Thanksgiving has a good Thanksgiving
planned. We will talk on the bonus show today,
what are my plans? What are producer Pat's plans?
Producer Pat's plans are much more interesting
than mine. He he will. He will tell us all about
it. A few stories that I did want to go over
with you guys. This story has gotten quite
a bit of attention. Multiple conservatives
have quit Fox News over what they say is the
increasing propaganda, particularly from Tucker
Carlson. And it's interesting for what they say,
and it's also interesting for what they don't
say and you'll see what I mean in a moment.
This is about Jonah Goldberg and Stephen
Hayes, who have resigned from Fox News
protesting the irresponsible voice of people
like Tucker Carlson. Hayes and Goldberg announced
Sunday night that they have resigned from Fox.
The pair wrote in a blog post for The Dispatch,
their online home that Tucker Carlson's Patriot
Purge propaganda film was the last straw.
Fox News still does real reporting, and there
are still responsible conservatives providing
valuable opinion and analysis, they wrote. But the
voices of the responsible are being drowned out
by the irresponsible, and Carlson is the case
in point. CNN and other news outlets outlets
described how Patriot Purge is disturbing
evidence of right wing radicalization,
complete with January six denialism and
paranoid descriptions of a new war on
terror targeting Republicans with references to
Guantanamo Bay and images of waterboarding. Now
this is interesting for a few different reasons.
First of all, the resignation came Sunday night
in advance of the one hour propaganda
documentary produced by Tucker Carlson about
the Kyle Rittenhouse case and the full interview
that Tucker Carlson did with Kyle Rittenhouse,
which we covered yesterday, which are incredible
propaganda pieces, total and for propaganda,
lionizing and making a hero out of
Kyle Rittenhouse portraying him even
as an expert on things like prosecutorial
misconduct, self-defense, the FBI. I mean,
completely out of this world propaganda. So it's
interesting that it was the Patriot Purge thing
that was sort of like the last straw. Now it's
interesting where these people draw the line.
Goldberg and Hayes are certainly more
along the lines of what we might call.
I hate to use the term like normal conservatives,
but sort of more traditional conservatives in the
line of like Mitt Romney and Liz Cheney. In
fact, mentioning Liz Cheney is interesting
because Liz Cheney even tweeted out a thank you
to Goldberg and Hayes for calling out the lies
on Fox from that patriot purge. Propaganda piece,
including the lies related to the 2020 election,
so that that's interesting because that's
clearly a contingent. But it's interesting
where people draw the line because Patriot Purge
is over the top. But Fox has been radicalizing
viewers forever in many different ways, and in
the months of the aftermath of the 2020 election,
they were giving voice to absolutely wacky
conspiracy theorists with completely fact
free views on the election and on and on and on.
So I don't want to belittle the fact that Goldberg
and Hayes said This is as far as we're going
and this is too much and we've got to leave.
That's fine. It's interesting because and
it's strange because the big picture of
what Fox News is and what Fox News does really
hasn't changed, actually for a very long time.
To be fair, Tucker has been particularly off
the deep end lately with the anti-vax stuff,
the Rittenhouse stuff, etc. So mentioning Tucker
is is sensible that that certainly makes sense.
The other thing about this is there likely to be
replaced with wackier people. And this is one of
the things where when Donald Trump during COVID
during his calling it administration of Cobra,
doesn't even make sense when he was president
during the pandemic and Donald Trump started
slamming Anthony Fauci. And increasingly,
people were asking, Why doesn't Fauci quit?
Why? Why stay in the situation? We said, and
maybe Fauci also said, I don't remember. I'm
just kind of going going from memory that if
he leaves, he may well be replaced with a yes
person of some kind rather than someone who's
going to insist on telling us what the science
actually is. And along those same lines, I don't
expect that Goldberg and Hayes are going to be
replaced on Fox News by more sensible people.
And that's always a question that comes up
when someone has had enough with something like
Fox News and they say, I'm taking myself out of
it. Often they get replaced with even more
radical voices, and that well may happen,
but we're going to watch it, and it's always
interesting to see where do they draw the line?
Jonah Goldberg and Stephen Hayes are drawing
the line at the Patriot Purge film from Sunday,
and it's not a crazy place to draw the line. It
was a completely whacked out film, but it will
be different for everyone. And of course, that
same film many conspiracy theorists seeing it and
saying Now we have Fox as well. We got. They are
now with us, and that's obviously very, very scary